[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
video on Harry Potter theory today we're
gonna go over something that JK Rowling
revealed in 2006 when a fan asked her
what would Hermione see if she were to
look in the mirror of error set now just
a bit of a backstory on the mirror of
Erised said in case you've forgotten how
it works the mirror of Erised said is a
magical mirror that shows us the deepest
most desperate desires of our hearts
this is reflected in mirrors name no pun
intended as error said flipped around
reads as desire the mirror itself was
made sometime before the end of the 19th
century and is located in the Room of
Requirement in Hogwarts engraved on the
mirror are the words era said straw
arrow Lloyd boob Caffrey
on Wasi which backwards reads as I show
not your face but your heart's desire
though it is speculated that the mirror
of Erised said was made for a bit of fun
it's worth noting that the mirror can be
exceedingly dangerous as reflected in
this quote by Dumbledore men have wasted
away before it not knowing if what they
have seen is real or even possible the
danger lies in people losing track of
reality after witnessing whatever it is
they've witnessed in the mirror they
become obsessed with what they've seen
and are completely unable to accept that
for the time being at least is just
fantasy nothing more it's natural for
human beings to desire things that are
unattainable and even more natural to
desire things period so almost everyone
sees something in the mirror however it
has been expressed but if someone who is
completely satisfied
meaning they already have everything
that they want in the world were to look
in the mirror then they would just see
themselves looking back at them the
mirror would act in a normal fashion the
mirror of Erised said is also famously
shown in the most recent fantastic beast
film and a sick piece the crimes of
Grindelwald in one eye con ik c n-- the
mirror shows a young Elvis Dumbledore
gazing into the
and seeing Gellert Grindelwald and
himself engaging in a Blood Pact in
which they swore to never fight each
other throughout the series we see some
of our favorite characters look into the
mirror of Erised said but not all of
them this gives us some creative freedom
to theorize or dig deeper in an attempt
to find out what it is that they would
see now we know that Harry looked into
the mirror in the Philosopher's Stone in
which he saw himself and his parents
Dumbledore looked into the mirror in
which he said he saw himself holding a
nice pair of socks
however if Hermione were to look into
the mirror what would she see
well according to an evening with Harry
Caray and GARP readings and questions
number 1 from August 1st 2006 JK Rowling
has this to say when someone asked I
just wanted to know what Hermione would
see if she looked into the mirror of
Erised said JK Rowling responded well at
the moment as you know Harry Ron and
Hermione have just finished their
penultimate year at Hogwarts and
Hermione and Ron have told Harry that
they're going to go with him wherever he
goes next so at the moment I think that
Hermione would seem most likely the
three of them alive and unscathed and
Voldemort finished but she goes on to
continue I think that Hermione would
also see herself closely entwined with
another person at this point the crowd
roars and applauds loudly I think you
can probably guess who thank you
very good question I've never been asked
that before so here we can see the
answer for ourselves from JK Rowling
back in 2006 now I believe Hermione
would see this exact same vision as well
because first and foremost she is very
selfless so she would love to see her
and her friends alive and safe and for
the biggest threat in the world that
being Voldemort to be finished and now
why I think JK Rowling added to that is
because once Voldemort was dead then she
could focus on herself and only then but
anything before that should make sure
her and her friends are safe if you guys
want a video on what every character
would see in the mirror of Erised said
and let us know down below thanks for
watching this quick video on Harry
Potter theory I hope you have an awesome
rest of your day and we'll see you in
the next episode until then you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]